come on well it's not gonna save itself
I'm driving we are a rumor recognizable
only as deja vu and dismissed this is
quickly we are the best-kept secret in
the universe I know I want in you erased
my parent's memories but you didn't get
mine took me 20 years to find you how
many people can say that I found you
which makes me perfect for this job
[Music]
how to do
you will be with agencies and my bu
Karelian scum and fYI your little Club
here sucks
come on well it's not gonna save itself
I'm driving that really should be here
Joey I thought that we were here we are
Freddie you go to H wait are you a queen
indeed she is I pledge loyalty eternal
to you no no I'm not interested too late
I already pledged the loyalty I wish
you'd said no no no before we've never
faced a threat like the hive they can
take the form but anyone I haven't seen
that before
our own agents do we have a plan
sometimes you have to trust your gut
men and black has been compromised on
trusts no one we protect the earth
and that means everyone and everything
on yeah we bother men in black
the men and women in black yeah
perfectly good are you suggesting that
we try the most powerful weapon in the
galaxy for fun do it press the button
turn it up as you
you